a local family finally has answers 18
years after a woman was murdered here in
Las Vegas Metro detectives connecting a
convicted murder to Keisha Brown's death
Sasha Loftus joining us live from Metro
Police Headquarters tonight now with
more
Brian Keisha Brown's daughter and her
entire family all here at today's news
conference they said they're grateful to
finally have some idea as to what
happened after so much time wondering
but with this log without knowing
anything that happened to my mom 18
years after her mom's brutal murder
Khalia Brown finally has closure her
entire family embracing after police
shared an update Thursday connecting
48-year-old Norman flowers to Keisha
Brown's October 2004 murder for the past
18 years detectives have investigated
this case and reviewed this case
multiple times Metro Thomas side
Lieutenant Jason Johansen says the year
old's boyfriend found her body in a
bathtub at this apartment near Flamingo
and University
set well tips came in no arrest was made
fast forward to last August when a Cold
Case reviewer recognized a pattern
related to the killings of three other
women in 2005 that flowers is already
serving three consecutive life sentences
for there's a sexual aspect to each one
of them there's the way in which the uh
the deaths occurred and there's a way
that the body was placed further DNA
testing linked flowers to Keisha's death
which Lieutenant Johansen believes was
the first in this series of slangs I
just want to say
the thank you to the police's Department
Those Who Loved Brown still devastated
but also grateful to finally have
answers the fact that I'm getting to
know this I'm just a thankful for it
now flowers is currently incarcerated at
High Desert State Prison in Indian
Springs he now faces multiple additional
charges for Keisha Brown's death
including open murder sexual assault and
burglary with a deadly weapon reporting
live tonight Sasha Loftus 8 News Now